another woman is detailing explosive
allegations against a longtime
gynecologist at the University of
Southern California
she joined 23 other women in an amended
lawsuit they accused dr. George Tyndall
of sexual misconduct including
assaulting patients under the guise of
medical treatment Tyndall is also under
investigation by the Department of
Education and the LAPD they're looking
into more than 50 cases some former
patients claim USC ignored complaints
about the doctor for decades and covered
up his alleged crimes Jamie yuccas spoke
with two women of and their lawyer
Gloria Allred when we went into the
examining room he had me undressed from
the waist down and he watched me as I
did that Daniela Mahasabha
Ana Nika Narayan in both visited USC
gynecologist dr. George Tyndall in 2016
he started asking me what race I was
relating me to how I looked like his
wife and you had never been to a
gynecologist I had never been to a
gynecologist before this was my first
visit he didn't give me any protective
covering so I was naked from the waist
down using two fingers he performed an
examination in deeply misogynistic
motion Maha's up says the doctor did not
use gloves and Narayan an says he asked
about position she used during sex
they both say he made sexually charged
comments about their bodies I think the
comments at the beginning were really
we're really off-putting and then the
physical examination felt very wrong but
I just thought that that might be how a
gynecologist appointment was like did
you speak up right away
I spoke to friends I spoke to parents
but it was my word against the doctors
and you know who was I to tell a doctor
that he was doing his job incorrectly we
believe that we have evidence that USA
knew as early as the 1990s about reports
of dr. Tyndall and we want to know what
do they know and when did they know it
why did they fail when you think about
the amount of women that went through
this
are we talking thousands we don't know
the extent and the scope of
harm ya what's the piece for both of you
that keeps you up at night
about this I think that USC knew about
it for so long is it of relief to you
that you're not alone or is it just
sickening to know that this happened to
so many people I think it's sickening
and disgusting that this happened to so
many people for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles Tyndale has
denied these accusations and has not
been criminally charged he was suspended
with pay in 2016 and retired in 2017
with a payout from the University
the USC Board of Trustees didn't respond
to our request for comment on the
amended lawsuit but says it welcomes the
Department of Education investigation
and will fully cooperate we reached out
to Tyndall but have not heard back yeah
we really would like to hear what he has
to say well this reminds us of course of
the USA Gymnastics actual assault
scandal it's very similar